kind and he's funny and he's also
mustachioed he solves all your problems
by the end of every episode
[Music]
all right we got some questions uh in
the inbox asking for advice okay
from Anonymous our daughter and middle
child is going through the common
toddler phase of whining and crying and
is super defiant
s-u-u-u-u-p-p-p-e-r-r-r so super
super defined about everything what do I
do I feel like I'm always getting after
her to quit acting that way but I feel
like I'm talking to a brick wall is this
something I need to fix in myself or our
daughter is this middle child behavior
toddler Behavior girl Behavior or a
combination of all three thanks for
everything and thank you Sean for asking
Matt to call Sean's not here thank you
Sean for asking Matt the question you
definitely need it she definitely needed
to deserve a raise uh okay so this is uh
uh this is toddler Behavior that's this
what the toddler years are all about
[Applause]
and a girl or boy you know we've gone
through this as you know with several
kids and uh and it's it's the same thing
toddlers are toddlers
you know saying things like you said you
get after her to quit acting that way
and we all we all lapse into this
sometimes you know it's just natural as
a parent but saying something I quit
knock it off like to actually say that
to a toddler is totally pointless it
doesn't they it doesn't mean anything to
them
[Music]
and what we also have to remember with
with children at that age is that uh is
is that you know their brains are very
far from fully developed and so they're
actually not they're not capable of
controlling themselves perfectly all the
time and really nobody is even adults no
one is perfect about it but for for
toddlers you know it's like they're this
is why people talk about the terrible
twos and everything I think I think that
the terrible two phase is way overblown
but the reason why you can and I also
you know not to be like the overly
sensitive type I'm not usually that but
I also I don't love putting a label like
terrible onto a a whole phase of life
especially when they're little kids you
know I don't think it's quite fair you
sure about that
you sure about that
but you know you have this kind of
Perfect Storm where they're um obviously
moving around now completely and they're
walking around and so they have their um
they're able to you know move around
that way
um and they're able to develop like
they've kind of figured out that there
is an option to say no you know when
they're younger like when the kids like
one one-year-old or something they
haven't even quite figured out that that
knows even an option
and another kind of figuring that out
and they're they're starting to test
boundaries a little bit
feel good so you've got that going on
they can speak now but they don't have
all of their language skills developed
yet so they're not able to ex really
explain
themselves and what they're actually
feeling have you ever had a dream
and so they could be frustrated about
something and they don't even know what
they're frustrated about and they're not
able to explain it to you it's all these
things come together to create the
toddler temper Dimensions but that's
also why just saying hey pipe down stop
it like stop it it does it doesn't do
anything okay you know what you need to
relax
they can hear that they're not going to
say oh oh I should stop it well okay
then father I will stop it right away so
what do we do about it I think that um
the first thing is to is to realize that
this is a natural part of childhood
doesn't doesn't mean that we accept it
all the time it doesn't mean you let
your kid act crazy all the time uh but
to realize that it is part of the
natural development process so it's not
like um it's not it's not it's not a
problem in the sense it's like you need
to worry about that it's a it's a
reflection of what's going to be in the
future this is just a toddler but as I
said you also don't laugh they're not
going to let them run the house and you
you do still want to teach them
discipline and all of that
so um I think that involves on your end
just being firm and being consistent
and being simple in the instructions
that you give to the child
and if you put rewards in place or you
put punishments in place being
consistent about those things so
firmness consistency
patience being calm
you know yelling at a toddler
never works it does it's not going to
get the reaction that you want hey I
want a lawyer
parents yell sometimes it happens but
it's not actually going to to help the
situation that's just you letting off
steam and also we are modeling that this
is the biggest challenge for parents and
I always have to remind myself of this
because I'm far from perfect as a parent
but uh it is true that the best thing I
can do for my kids is actually model the
behavior that I want to see in them so
yes I'm going to set rules in place and
I'm going to say this is what you need
to do and I'm going to give instructions
and we're gonna do all that as a parent
but we also have to model it and so
particularly for a toddler if you want
them to be patient if you want them to
control their emotions if you want them
to listen to instructions if you want
all that stuff out of a toddler the best
way to get it is to show that and I
think for a lot of parents they get
overwhelmed by the toddler phase and
they start getting angry and they yell a
lot but now you're you're just
demonstrating that to the kid so you're
saying something but they don't hear
that all they see is what you're doing
and so now they're emulating it um so
leaning by example is a and then things
like you know redirecting
I think is often a good strategy for for
toddlers they really want something
they're freaking out about it because
they can't get it redirect them to
something else doesn't mean that you're
bribing them all the time you know I'm
not saying that they're freaking X they
want to do something you don't want to
do it and you say oh here's a lollipop
and you try to bribe them that's that's
not going to be a good strategy but
redirecting them to something their
energy is to something more something
better uh and ignoring is all is is a
tool in the parenting Arsenal that has
to be used sometimes uh as long as you
know that you know you've addressed
their concern they're not hurt there's
nothing serious going on
um they're still
having an attitude having a temper
tantrum sometimes it's like you gotta
just
ignore it in certain circumstances not
not like when you're out of the grocery
store and they're having a temper
tantrum and you let them do it and
disrupt everybody around you that's when
you have to get them out of the
situation but um there are circumstances
where you do that like yesterday when I
was putting my three-year-old down for
for bed and uh she was very very upset
about going to bed even though it was
actually past your bedtime and I did try
to explain that to her I said this 30
minutes past your bedtime so you know
you should be you should be thanking me
but for some reason she was not
persuaded by that she's very upset about
going to bed and uh she was not a
full-on meltdown but she was like
whining about it and
yeah I explained to her it's bedtime
you're going to bed brought her up gave
her a kiss so good night
left her but and she was still whining
but I'm not going to sit there and
negotiate with you it's like this is
bedtime and then and then I left and she
was fine and she got over you know men
hate going to the doctor you have to
make the appointment you have to spend
half your day sitting around the waiting
room you have to endure uncomfortable
conversations about your body with
another man that you hardly know Rex MD
understands that no one likes to go to
the doctor's office that's why they've
created a safe online platform for men
to discreetly consult with licensed
Physicians and get personalized
treatment plans Rex MD makes it easy and
inexpensive to get the generic and
branded Viagra or Cialis online no
waiting rooms no embarrassing trips to
the doctor no insurance no co-pays did
you know Viagra could cost 90 a pill
your XMD has generic bag or for just as
low as two dollars a pill just fill out
their online medical questionnaire a
doctor will review your situation and if
appropriate prescribe your medication
medication will ship right to your door
with free two-day shipping it's fast
it's simple it's cheap plus you can
access your us license or XMD physician
anytime you need Rex MD has already
helped over 300 000 guys gain confidence
quickly and conveniently they are here
to help they can help you to take
advantage of their best deal yet at
rexmd.com Walsh and save up to 90 off by
paying only two dollars per dosage
that's rexmd.com walls for up to 90 off
go to rexmd.com for more details and
safety information all right from Ray
says Dear Matt please help me figure out
my marriage I've been married just over
five years and have four kids five and
under we recently moved states to Utah
he's got a better job here and I don't
have to work I used to be the heavy
earner
I love being able to stay at home with
my three little boys and my nursing baby
girl
I cook all the meals to save money the
house is clean I homeschool I'm involved
in several Church groups I don't dump
all the hardships of my daily life on my
husband because of your advice not to do
this
it's good good advice if I do say so
myself I share stories of the sweet
things our little babies do and general
news and some fun things I think that
he'd like to hear about
that's all very good my husband
constantly complains he complains about
work he complains that we have to buy a
house in this state and how it'll be so
expensive and he'll have to pay for it
alone he complains about the kids
interrupting him while he's looking at
the phone he complains about stubbing
his toe he complains about the weather I
try not to be heard or offended by this
because we did leave his childhood home
to come here I had to leave mine when we
were married because California is not a
good place it's just so so hard to stay
positive if I'm happy when he comes home
he'll say things like well I'm glad
you're happy because that commute is an
absolute killer it'll keep on about
little things like the food being pricey
or the beer being the wrong kind or the
baby being cranky until I'm crying then
he'll say well you wanted to move here
so stop crying I don't know what to do I
try so hard to be supportive and
uncomplaining but I can't I can tell
he's really unhappy I've asked him to
try to give me the same courtesy of
being just happy when he comes home but
he says that he's then he just says what
I'm not allowed to have feelings now
then he'll yell at our boys or for
whatever they're doing what do I say
what do I do I don't even know where to
start I want to be supportive but I
actually hate being around him because
of how much he nags at me and yells at
the kids please advise
so the first thing
always is to look at yourself that
that's the first person you can control
in your marriage you know the only
person you could directly control in the
in the entire universe so that's always
the first place that you want to look
and I'm not saying this is your fault I
don't know anything about you so
um you have presented a pretty one-sided
version of events here and it could be
totally accurate no indication that it
isn't but um nine times out of ten or
maybe like 9.9 times out of ten you hear
a story like this if I were to talk to
your husband he would have his own tale
of Woe uh related to you and and what
you do and um that that would also
probably be rather one-sided and then
between those two pictures maybe we
would get a clearer picture of what the
truth is and that's not again not any
criticism to do that's just how people
are you know that's that's how that's
how I tell anybody is
um if I were to complain about somebody
in my life and you talk to that person
they would have their own complaints
that's the way it goes so the way that
you have laid this out this version of
the story he comes he's totally the bad
guy he's being completely unreasonable
you are not you know you're trying to be
happy and supportive and you're doing
all these things at home and the house
is clean and you're making food you're
taking care of the kids and you're happy
to see them and you're you tell them
happy stories and and all of that and
but he's complaining all the time about
everything he's whining and self-pitying
my only point is that as a matter of
Statistics uh it's very likely that the
story is not as one-sided as you
have made it out to be boom roasted so I
would look at yourself is it actually
true this is this is is this is this
true or is this a story you're telling
about
yourself and then after you've you've
done that inventory
um
you know there is a question about is
there something else going on in his
life you know is this is this just
childish whining or is there something
more serious going on is there something
going on at work
um some major stress some major burden
that he's carrying that he doesn't want
to tell you about uh because he doesn't
want to put it on your shoulders but
then unfortunately he's not putting that
on your shoulders but then he's he's
putting everything else on your
shoulders because it comes out in these
delays that's a possibility I would try
to talk to him about that
once you have covered those bases
um and if it is true that this is
basically a one-sided thing there's
nothing else more serious going on with
him
um then we are left with in that case
that on his part this is
this is just simply self-centeredness
this is
being a
being super whiny and and being
self-pitying you know this is someone
who wants pity who wants attention and
wants pity and there are people like
that in the world there are a lot of
people like that and unfortunately there
are men like that
um and it is uh a real problem
especially when men become this way
because it's not respectable it's not
respectable Behavior it's very hard to
respect someone who's who desires pity
all the time and uh even when you're
trying to have a positive conversation
or telling about the kids and all he
wants to do is complain he doesn't want
to see you happy like he's he comes home
and you're happy and he's like upset
about that so he wants to tell you about
oh you're happy well here's what
happened to me what's the matter I think
it's a matter if that's all the case
then that that's that's not a good thing
he had a tough day at work and he comes
home and everybody's happy that should
make him even happier that's like that's
a great thing to come home to happiness
my my goodness so if that's the case
then
then it really becomes a man-up
situation for him and I know there are
guys like in the manosphere and all that
that they don't like that phrase they
don't want to hear about that
um they never want to hear that answer
but sometimes that is the answer like
sometimes for a man just get the hell
over it be a man
[Music]
but really that that's the only solution
in that case and if that's it then uh
then you'd still need to have a talk to
him and with them and and um
you know that's when you're talking
about things like respect and you want
to respect him but it's hard to respect
this kind of behavior you start using
language like that that really
now he might react to he might get angry
at first but that will resonate there's
a chance of getting through it's going
to be when you start using language like
that you're not being vicious to him
you're not saying you don't respect him
you're just saying I can't respect this
Behavior
so that's what I would say uh finally
for Michelle I'm married to a very kind
and godly man he's both my husband and
my best friend my entire family loves
him except for my sister every time I
see her she has something negative to
say about him she has never brought
anything concerning or serious to me
about him I believe she just doesn't get
along with him because they're they have
clashing personalities I feel disloyal
listening to her say unkind things about
my husband however I don't want to cause
drama with my sister what should I say
when she comes to me with complaints
about my husband uh you you can't listen
to complaints about your husband
at all um if if there's something really
serious going on that's someone in your
life is concerned about
um and they bring that to you that's one
thing but you're saying there's nothing
serious here he's a very good man and so
she's just whining about him and nagging
you know and like Nick nitpicking and
that sort of thing
um no I don't I don't think you don't
you don't you don't have those kinds of
conversations about your about your
husband with with anybody
um complaining about them listening to
complaints you can talk to our complaint
department it's a trash can it's not
appropriate you know you should not be
the sounding board for anyone's
complaints about your husband just like
he shouldn't be
for any complaints about you
um so that's what you tell your sister
so I'm not going to listen to this it's
not appropriate it's not right
um I love and respect my husband We're
not gonna have this conversation and I
don't want to hear it anymore
um and then she just has to do it okay
well we'll leave it there thanks for
listening talk to you tomorrow
[Music]